heavy-metal yoga studios you know where
it's like I think about all these other
places where there could be innovation
that tie to our general mission of like
health that's like do we like what if
liquid death creates like a chain of
heavy-metal yoga studios you know where
it's like people who want to do yoga but
they don't want to listen to Yanni when
they're doing it like is there some room
for like some kind of cool like how do
you make it I totally knew you could do
like this experience you could do like
tough-guy multi-vitamins community right
healthy product multivitamins and be
like okay cool building actually you
know rainbows and Care Bears like maybe
we could just make this form factor a
little different brand a little
different right to speak to a different
audience use you know so you you guys
have raised let's say 10 I forget the
number 10 or 12 million dollars
you're not huge yet you're definitely
still getting going how do you decide so
like at my company we have a brand that
people know and people just if we make
stuff people will buy it but in my head
I'm always like I don't want to make
other stuff let's just like focus on
what we're doing and kick ass at that
and then maybe eventually expand whereas
you've done these little experiments
like the vinyl record inmate so maybe
you're also trying to uh maybe you
weren't joking with your heavy metal
yoga thing in my head I'm like no no
that focus what uh do you have like
a like logistically how do you decide
where to throw a bunch of that and throw
money at in order to so let me ask you
that so this this is what I mean all
these other products that we could
potentially make that actually sell or
actually succeed they double as
marketing for the water yeah this is
marketing that its profitable its
profitable exactly it's like we made a
vinyl record I can't tell you how many
eyeballs that got liquid death on from
people reposting the album sharing the
album talking about it and that album
for us to execute including printing the
vinyl cost us $12,000 and we've already
made all of our money how much did you
have work on the
well how much stat who worked on it but
you know did you we hired a guy that we
knew that was a friend of a friend who's
an incredible metal musician who wrote
the whole album his name's Gus Rios he
wrote and recorded the whole album his
buddy mixed the whole album and his body
mix stuff for Justin Bieber and all
these other guys so we got the whole
album recorded we made a commercial for
maybe 2 grand on stock footage and my
wife edited the video so I was like you
know that's all that's all we launched
with it was a little launch video made
with stock footage and we pressed
records and sold the records in our
merch store and it's like all that stuff
adds together that's why it's like what
would it cost to to start let's call it
a chain of five looks small heavy metal
yoga studios in LA like small little
studios not a lot going on you find some
you know some instructors like maybe you
could actually build that out for call
it 500 grand let's just say like you can
make you could build a five chain yo go
studio heavy metal yoga studio chain for
a 500 grand
what does 500 gram buy you if you try to
run one TV spot right during the
Oscars like maybe you get a 30-second
spot and what's gonna see more lifts and
brand evangelism for your brand running
one $500,000 commercial during the
Oscars or building a chain of five heavy
metal yoga studios in LA that gets
talked about by every publication heavy
metal yoga studio launches in their leg
people actually go to it everyone who
goes takes photos and shares and talks
it's like that's a way
smarter way to spend your money and you
might actually make some of it back if
it's a good enough business model you
know this is like Elon selling
flamethrowers right yeah he is the you
know sort of iron man trying to be a
badass rockets and you know drilling
into underground and electric sports
cars so he comes out with the
flamethrower for seven hundred dollars I
think it was and he sold
he sold like millions shit-ton I think
it was
millions of dollars and the whole thing
is basically just being like you know
feeding the evangelism like you said of
the cult of yuan of yeah life should be
a little more badass we need a little
more fire a little more speed and a
little more like you know rocketry to in
our in our lives and so it's the brand
[Music]
[Applause]